zero emission no noise the zen car was
meant to be the car of a future where
greenhouse gases would be banished but
achieving that scenario has been
anything but zen motorheads have shunned
green machines meaning alternative fuels
only account for 10 of the market the eu
blames this on the lack of
infrastructure
they can
under new rules voted on by meps eu
countries would have to set up a minimum
number of recharging points and
standardized plug points for electric
vehicles amongst other measures but
going green comes at cost which the
commission estimates to be around 10
billion euros that the main difficulty
is and would be with member states about
the financial burden
connected to this directory because it's
not so clear who is going to pay
for the development of this kind of
infrastructures the suggestion of
taxpayers footing the bill left the
greens cold this doesn't work but this
is this is the same as usual
and the other political parties here
have supported it and i think that's a
bad move i think it's bad for europe
it's bad for air quality it's bad for
climate change now the report will be
discussed with national governments but
some want to pull the plug
it's the classical fault a lot of
colleagues make here in brussels they
want to regulate it very much it's far
too complicated now i will be one of the
negotiators there will be very difficult
negotiations with such tough talk
negotiators might be wise to take a leaf
from the book of zen if they want a deal
before election time in may